the pokemons and detective Pikachu have
a new look and they've never seen more
real or terrifying that's in large part
thanks to this guy RJ Palmer a concept
artist at ubisoft I draw creatures and
monsters and I worked on detective
Pikachu he started drawing when he was
just three years old he continued to
hone his craft at the San Francisco
Academy of Art then in 2012 his drawings
for an amateur fan art project gained so
much attention on the Internet it
ultimately landed him a job on the new
Pokemon film so I started drawing like a
shark dinosaur and that turned into the
Pokemon Garchomp and people really
really responded to it so I kept like
drawing more RJ used real animals as an
inspiration the natural world is so
inspiring and I think pulling from that
as much as possible is like really cool
for example Mewtwo was a combination of
several creatures kangaroo and a little
bit of rhino and hairless cat and some
barn owl for Charizard he focused on
different lizards so I looked a lot of
monitor lizards and like sort of brought
qualities look like crocodilians in
there that I liked as well surprisingly
enough RJ's main tools for designing his
realistic Pokemon were simply a Wacom
tablet and Photoshop can I've got like a
second monitor up so I can have all my
references ultimately it was the amount
of time and effort RJ poured into the
project that made his Pokemon come to
life
RJ researched every animal he used for
inspiration and in the end each Pokemon
he created took 30 or more hours to
complete the one that took the longest
to make is tyrantrum
tyrantrum is my favorite pokemon he
posted them on the popular fan art
community site deviantART and his work
won over fans on the Internet
it also got the attention of the
production designer of Detective Pikachu
he gives me a call and it's like he's
like would you like to work on the
Pokemon movie and you know I'm shocked
it was amazing I've always been like
really into Pokemon as just like a
franchise because I think it's really
fun and creative
[Music]
he moved to LA and worked on the film
for seven months doing concept art for
characters and the environments
he helped come up with the initial
designs for the pokemons
and then you know it gets given to like
all sorts of crazy effects house while
his Pokemon on deviantART are more
realistic the ones he designed for the
film had to be a bit more traditional
you know excite working on the movie
like they had to get a more inline with
the cartoon aesthetic I think you do a
design and then people have opinions and
then you do another design and they
he'll also still have opinions and you
know so it's just like a constant back
and forth of trying to make you know one
person happy which you know is gonna
make somebody else unhappy and then you
have to try and find a middle ground
that's gonna work for people
Pikachu as the star of the film and
franchise took a while to nail down and
get right Pikachu is like one of the
most well known cartoon characters ever
right despite speaking English and being
a bit more furry than the cartoon the
Pikachu in the film is different from
his realistic design I based him on
rodents and lagomorph slag remorse or
like rabbits just like you know like
small woodland critters but it was mr.
mime that really grabbed the Internet's
attention since his debut in the trailer
he's become a meme mr. mime was always
gonna be weird right because what do you
make that thing when I did my realistic
version of it I made out of frog because
like it can be so many weird things I
think a detail that I didn't you know
know they were gonna go for but when
they like the the little shoulder
pauldrons actually look like kick balls
I thought that was a pretty fun idea and
the jigglypuff I like in the Pokedex
injuries they talked about it having a
balloon-like skin texture which would
probably be pretty creepy in real life
so they made it more furry with a curly
wisp of hair in the end though it's the
fans who have the final say everybody
has their own idea of what pokemon is
and I've certainly encountered that
working on my own stuff I've had some
very divisive takes on certain Pokemon
so like I knew that was was gonna be a
problem going in to the movie and like
so far at least the response to the
trailer at least from the circles that
I've seen is
pretty positive pipe yes okay I can
shoving pushing my problem is that I
push people away and then hate them for
leaving he's saying you can shove it
what I can shove it okay that's it no
we're switching roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop